[Música]
de vuelta a cultura france24 tras una
pausa vacacional es un placer saludarles
esta semana en el dualismo de tres
artistas y personajes en el programa
siendo el primero banxico como creador
callejero el entorno es un lienzo y por
esa dualidad inicial una exposición en
bruselas se plantea cuánto de genio o de
vándalo hay en el de bristol que
recordarán semi autodestruyó su niña con
globo tras una venta en subasta con un
recorrido por su influencia en el
graffiti y su crítica e impacto social
imaginada de qué lado se decanta la
muestra ya que a veces tras el talento
de ideas como la gente que disfruta
agitando banderas no merece tener una no
siempre se entiendo de este arte efímero
cuya sensación se transmite aquí
digitalmente
esta exposición contiene obras
auténticas de banshee y eso es
importante también contamos con una
experiencia multimedia en la que
intentamos mostrar el arte callejero en
un ambiente real porque a menudo de los
graffitis duran poco tiempo además
tenemos la parte de realidad virtual
porque mucha gente que viene a ver la
exposición nunca ha tenido ninguna
relación con el arte callejero nunca ha
tenido esa sensación de tener que huir
con las pinturas en la mano
nat crivillé habló con nuestra
corresponsal en bélgica esther herrera
quien con estas 80 obras auténticas
cedidas por coleccionistas nos lleva a
ese otro ying yang de banks y el
anonimato de alguien tan célebre si la
exhibición tiene ese ambiente del
misterio y de rebeldía es porque
personifica el grafitero con una
identidad tan en la sombra que ni se
molesta en autorizar esta u otras
muestras sobre él sabemos que empezó a
ser banks y entre el 92 94 que en el
2000 organizó una exposición en londres
que derivó en toda su visión aguda sobre
el break si la política o la migración y
que ahora los derechos de autor son los
únicos en incitar la revelar su
identidad de robyn
este junio perdió la autoría de cuatro
obras solo que hasta ahora ha actuado
más como esta expo ubicada irónicamente
en un antiguo banco de las campas
si no da apoyo a ninguna exposición que
no la haya hecho el propio band si de
hecho hay muy pocas pero si intentamos
contactar con él y contactamos con su
organización veces control
intentamos informarles sobre la
colección qué es lo que hacemos qué es
lo que no seguir unas normas claro que
hemos intentado contactar con van sí
pero claro nadie sabe quién es así que
es un poco difícil
dt
del coliseo pocos conocían su subsuelo y
casi dos mil años después de su
construcción aquí está más de 80
arqueólogos restauradores y arquitectos
han devuelto a nuestros ojos los
hipogeos es decir los niveles
subterráneos por los que enfilaban
prisioneros animales y gladiadores
suenan sencillos pero se basan en un
muro perimetral y 14 tabiques que tejen
una red de 15 pasillos anulares con
habitaciones y jaulas si el anfiteatro
permitía 70 mil de aforo y su arena
podía llenarse de agua para batallas
estas bambalinas de las peleas son un
monumento en sí mismas una pasarela de
160 metros ya permite recorrer su pasado
luego de dos años de trabajo y una
financiación parcial de la marca de moda
tod's
en otras noticias artístico patrimonial
es el protagonista de rembrandt su óleo
y la adoración de los magos que se creía
perdido y que en 2016 cayó de la pared
de un coleccionista está cerca de
atribuírsele tras un estudio que además
sugiere que podría ser un boceto para
grabar justo cuando por primera vez en
tres siglos sus paisanos de hernández se
han visto completa la ronda de noche
gracias a la inteligencia artificial su
historia es pura amputación en 1715 al
no entras por las puertas del
ayuntamiento fue cortada a trozos
grandes con tijeras el precio de su
nuevo hogar fue perder esos bordes que
hoy han sido reconstruidos a partir de
una pequeña copia del 17 si bien el
dinamismo de la composición es temporal
dijimos tres dualidades y la segunda es
sweet tough que da paso a lo audiovisual
por un lado esta serie es tan dulce como
el jarabe de arce que tanto gusta a su
protagonista casi un héroe de la
esperanza más que un niño ciervo cuyo
aprendizaje se da en un mundo devastado
por un virus mortal que brotó hace diez
años coincidiendo con el nacimiento de
otros niños híbridos no diremos que ni
cómo se da la distopía tranco 19 pero la
mera existencia de gas generará las
respuestas que él necesita y que
necesita esta humanidad sobreviviente y
dividida
[Música]
en vivo reuters
soy negro media de bronce
[Música]
u2
este miércoles la verdad
el tallo
dónde está su cara b1 en su cómico
original de hace 12 años la de jeff
lemire paradis y comics es oscurísima de
trazo grueso y sombrío incluidas las
orejas peludas de gas pero no es una
crítica a lo dual funciona y casa con la
versión aventurera de netflix que a su
vez tiene contradicciones morales el
papá de gas lo protege pero lo priva de
su identidad su madre crea un bien con
un mal mientras que la cuestión de fondo
es hasta qué punto los seres podemos
usar la naturaleza sin causar
consecuencias o mutilar la para una
salvación para remate uno de los
productores ejecutivos no es sino robert
downey junior ironman que lejos del
universo marvel ha sabido ampliar esta
adaptación
ninguna obtenía
benítez
[Música]
a deus cargo como eres rico
mientras europa y américa del norte
lanzan mascarillas al aire sudamérica es
epicentro del virus ante este dolor el
streaming de una cartelera biosegura dan
consuelo y acción en concreto con un
cine no a tributo a los dramas
criminales de los 50s saber ver nos
lleva a detroit donde unos delincuentes
contratados para robar un documento se
topan con capas de corrupción organizada
en la capital de la automotriz pueden
imaginar por dónde van los tiros con un
elenco muy saga ocean's ansiosos de
trabajar entre sí ya que en trafic ni
chile ni benicio llegaron a cruzarse
pero además por soderbergh que se dice
cucarachas de la industria por no haber
parado en pandemia se siente esa alegría
de filmar de nuevo aún siendo en un set
de borbón tuvo el mismo examen was mal
aunque si de evadirse se trata que tal
un viaje al 2000 51 para luchar contra
mortales alienígenas chris pratt lidera
esta ciencia ficción de amazon junto a
soldados y civiles dispuestos a apoyar a
una humanidad que está perdiendo una
guerra extraterrestre y por ende su
futuro régimen spaces pontes opinión de
facebook y ver todo lo contrario de
black widow que si por fin tiene trama
en solitario mira al pasado de una
natasha romanoff free avengers' y sin
voluntad de ser una historia de
espionaje el alias de scarlett johansson
deberá enfrentar una conspiración
cuestionando quien es su amigo de verdad
entre ellos el ron de florence book que
la ayuda en este inicio de la cuarta
fase
y con jean-paul tamayo cerramos el
círculo de los dualismos al cantautor
independiente talento de nuestra casa
hermana radio francia internacional lo
conocimos en 2019 bajo este nombre y un
tumbao salsero que no tenía límites solo
que tras una mutación más positiva que
la del doctor jekyll a quien presentamos
hoy es a caleño su versión anhelada con
más gusto por las letras y el hip-hop y
numerosos artistas se lanzan a otros
registros pero en su caso viene de cuna
siendo de la salsa de sus vivencias en
colombia a la afinidad por el rap y la
electrónica de su francia natal
yo viví una temporada en cali en los
años 90 y cuando regrese al final de los
90 era el auge del hip hop realmente
aquí en francia una generación de
raperos de aquí en francia y se me
influenció mucho ellos mismos venían
influenciadas por el rap y de equipos de
eeuu
entonces uno como que se carga de todo
eso
[Aplausos]
[Música]
puedo decir también que en cierta forma
está la dualidad de moderno con
tradicional porque porque ciertamente la
salsa es una música tradicional y a la
vez me parece que el rapper se parece
mucho al sonero de la salsa que expresó
sus mensajes en rimas que habla de temas
de sociedad que habla del cotidiano que
habla de temas que tocan a la humanidad
si a soderbergh le dio por producir los
oscar y reversionar cintas la pandemia
ha permitido a caleño sacar a ese otro
personaje gracias a su unión mágica con
el compositor lukas simonet luego de un
año su disco luz trasera el tercero pero
primero en este tono exhibe a esta
transformación con mensajes sobre el
cambio climático o las reivindicaciones
en colombia siguiendo el hip hop más
social y político así es muy interesante
como proceso porque por ejemplo cuando
entramos al estudio entonces con lukas
los inicios y yo era la primera vez que
iba a poner mi voz en unas composiciones
y en una música investiga música que no
fuera salsa entonces al principio él me
decía no no no no estás cantando como si
estuvieras cantando salsa
[Música]
en octubre si me pierdo en la ciudad
buscando lo que no se me ha vendido
todos piensan que hay a veces carreteras
que están llevan luz pero cuando la
noche es oscura pues uno se fija más en
la luz roja del carro que va adelante
cuando hay una curva larga poniéndolo va
siguiendo también para orientarse es
como la metáfora de smalling es que la
inspiración también que lo guía uno en
el camino de la vida pues porque en el
disco quise expresar temas que que me
inspiran sencillamente y
y que hablan de mí de mi condición de
artista de las decisiones que tomaba
para decidir ser artista y vivir de ser
artista y vivir de mi arte en el otro
lado jean-paul abarca la migración de un
continente a otro y es en buscar un
mejor mañana un mañana en el que en lo
individual espera llevarla toda américa
latina a su música gracias por su
compañía y cuídense
cada vez que me acuerdo qué mejor que me
vuelva a encontrar vida vueltas la mente
ya no sé cómo actuar
la familia y el miedo al qué dirán no sé
qué camino seguir aquí la sociedad dice
que tengo que pensar en esa seguridad
pero yo me voy más por la aventura ahora
me encanta no saber ciencia
y lo que me propongo va a funcionar
[Música]
no te espera
era